sure not far from PS 12 which I
mentioned is PS 28 which is bed-stuy the
other side of Atlantic Avenue this is
school where over 40% of kids are
homeless and the the principal there's
34 highly it's a highly effective school
high-performing school the principal
there when I when I took a tour there
last year she introduced me to her
secretary
she said I've trained my secretary to do
most of my administrative jobs I said
well then what do you do she says I am
the lead teacher at the school I'm in
classrooms all day I work with teachers
and I teach the kids the teachers don't
know how to teach because I want to make
it clear to my teachers that I didn't
become a principal to escape the
classroom I became a principal to be the
leader of the classrooms and I watched
her as she interacted with with teachers
and it was very clear that she saw them
as colleagues as part of a team that
even though she was clearly the leader
she was also there to support them and
at one point said well how do you get
along with the Union she said let me
introduce my union rep and it was very
clear that they were partners in this
effort and working well together so you
know what she has is something that is
very difficult to teach is which is a
high degree of social intelligence she
knows how to work with people she knows
how to bring the best out of people she
knows how to read people and understand
their strengths at one point when I was
listening to school she said she took me
to a small office where there was a
older man counseling a little boy and I
said she said you see that man there I
said yeah and she says I got him from
the rubber room now those people who
don't know New York the rubber room is a
place where they put teachers and school
staff that nobody wants and they stay
there indefinitely and get paid and it's
a really horrendous situation so I said
to her I said how did he know to get him
out of the rubber room she said well I
don't know why he was there but he had
been my counselor when I was a kid in
school so when I heard he was in the
rubber room I asked for him and I
brought into my school so I sat in and I
interest myself and they interested to
the little boy who was there talking to
him so
the counselor said ask this little boy
why he's here today so I said why are
you here boys about eight years old he
says I'm learning how to be good so you
learn how to be good
as I said it's working he said I hope so
because I'm tired of getting in trouble
all the time and what struck me was it
was there was the it was a conversation
it was a friendly conversation going on
between this older man his little boy it
wasn't about we're gonna throw you out
of school we're gonna punish you it was
about trying to really get at the roots
of helping this boy learn to become
responsible for his own behavior not
enough schools do that students would
rather watch a big thing video then sit
and read a long page of text in a
textbook they have an opportunity to get
the information that they wouldn't
necessarily otherwise have we're using
the technologies to connect to learn
students can participate by using the
internet to their advantage